question de l'aude jeunes combien pèse
les nuages ça peut être très lourd même
si sa flotte au dessus de nos têtes et
que les avions traversent la plupart
d'entre eux sont problème un nuage peut
peser des dizaines voire des centaines
de milliers de tonnes en fait le poids
d'un nuage dépend de la densité de l'eau
qui contient alors dans un nuage cette
eau peut se présenter sous différentes
formes sous forme gazeuse c'est de la
vapeur sous forme liquide là vous avez
deviné c'est de la pluie ou alors sous
forme solide de la neige ou des graines
et puis il faut aussi prendre en compte
le volume du nuage c'est-à-dire son
étendue et sa hauteur et là ça va de
quelques mètres pour un cumulus jusqu'à
plusieurs kilomètres
quand il ya un orage tenez vous bien
certains cumulonimbus peuvent atteindre
15 km de hauteur et contenir jusqu'à 800
mille tonnes d'eau pour les plus gros et
les plus lourds